- [Voiceover] What I
wanna do in this video
is give ourselves a quick
overview of the different ways
that cells can communicate
with each other.
And maybe the most basic one,
is just through direct contact
and this can happen
several different ways.
One way could be,
you just have neighboring cells
so this is one cell right over here,
and this is the neighboring
cell right over here.
And they actually might have
gaps in their membranes.
If these are plants cells
we would call these gaps, gap junctions.
I just drew two of them
and this is obviously
just a two-dimensional slice.
So we're not fully appreciating
the three-dimensional structure,
but the basic idea is that
maybe the cell on the left
starts producing some molecules,
especially some small molecules
that are able to go through
these gap junctions.
And when they're able to go
through the gap junctions,
maybe they latch on to some
proteins in the second cell
that start maybe activating
them in a certain way,
or inhibit them in a certain way,
or trigger some type of reaction.
And so then you have a
response in the second cell.
So this would be a form of communication.
Something happened in this first cell
to produce these molecules.
Those molecules were able
to get into the second cell,
and trigger a response.
And as I mentioned, if
these are animal cells,
we would call these gaps,
we'd call them gap junctions.
So that right over there,
that is a gap junction.
And we covered this in other videos.
And if we're talking about plant cells
we can have very similar things happening,
but we wouldn't call them gap junctions.
These would be gaps,
not even tunnels through the membrane,
it would also be through the cell walls.
If we were talking about plants,
they would be plasmodesmata.
And we'd talk about these more
in The Structure of Cell videos.
But there is other ways
that you could communicate
via direct contact.
You could imagine maybe some cells
that are floating around
in the blood stream.
Maybe this is one cell over here,
maybe this is another cell over here.
And they have complementary
surface proteins.
Surface proteins that are
able to bind to each other.
So maybe this one has a surface protein
that looks like this.
I'm obviously exaggerating its shape,
the protein wouldn't look exactly like
this inverted triangle.
But this one has a
surface protein like this,
and I'm also exaggerating
it's size relative to a cell,
just so we can appreciate
how they could maybe lock together.
So this one has a surface
protein like that.
And when they bind to each other
it might change the proteins in some way,
and then trigger a reaction
in each of these cells.
That the communication then continues.
If this protein changes a little bit,
it might activate something.
It might activate the
release of some molecules,
it might activate some other proteins,
it might catalyze some type of reaction.
We've seen this in multiple other videos,
all sorts of crazy biological reactions
can happen inside of cells.
But it might illicit a,
it could illicit a response.
And actually it could even
illicit a response in both cells,
some type of response.
They know that they are
latched-on to someone else.
Now direct contact you could imagine,
is not the only way that you
could have cell-cell signaling.
You could actually have
cells start to signal
over a little bit of a distance,
by releasing molecules into
the extracellular space
and eventually even into the blood stream.
So, for example,
let me draw a cell right over here,
and maybe it's able to
produce some molecules.
And these molecules either,
they might be lipid soluble
and maybe make their way
through the cellular
membrane on their own.
Or, maybe they are packed in nice vesicles
that allow them to traverse the membrane.
So when you get actually,
so the membrane of the vesicle
merges with the membrane of the cell.
And then it allows
these things to get out.
And so you could imagine,
if another cell has the
right receptors for these,
that would signal some type of a response
or it will form some
form of communication.
So let's say that I have,
actually let me draw a couple of cells.
So let's say I have this cell over here,
and then I have this cell over here.
And let's say that this
cell has the right receptor,
and this cell doesn't.
It could have other receptors,
maybe it has receptors like that
but it's not the right receptor.
And so these molecules that
were released by this first cell
could bind not on this character,
not on this surface protein,
but it could bind on this character.
So it could bind on this character
and when it does so,
this protein that's on
the cellular membrane,
it might change its shape,
it might do all sorts of things.
But that signal can be then taken somehow,
it can continue on into
the cell and once again,
you might illicit some type of response.
And we'll go into more
detail in future videos
on exactly how that happens,
or what these responses actually might be.
Now, if this is over a short distance,
if this is a short distance,
short distance,
we would call this paracrine.
This would be part of
the paracrine system,
or we would call this
paracrine communication.
Let me write that down,
paracrine system,
or paracrine communication,
or paracrine signaling,
and we would call these paracrine factors.
But if it was happening
over long distances,
say maybe these molecules
they enter into the blood stream,
so they make their way
into the blood stream
right over here.
So let me depict somehow that
this is the blood stream.
So this is the blood stream,
and they're able to go
through the blood stream
over longer distances to other molecules.
So maybe this one has the right receptors
for those molecules.
Then we'd call this the endocrine system,
or this is endocrine signaling.
So long distances,
we would call this the endocrine system,
or endocrine signaling.
And we're talking about
the endocrine system
and endocrine signaling,
these molecules which could just be,
there could be all sorts of
different types of molecules.
They could be steroids,
they could be proteins of some kind.
In this case, we would call them hormones.
And you've probably heard the word before
and we will do a whole
series of videos on hormones.
But these molecules
actually could even affect
the cell that produced them.
For example, the cell that produced it
might have the right receptor.
And so, if it's able to signal,
if it's able to trigger
a reaction in itself,
so if these things are able to
trigger a reaction in itself,
we would call that an autocrine process.
It is acting on itself.
And just so you're familiar
with some of the terminology,
these proteins on the surface,
and this would be the case
especially if you have
non-lipid soluble types
of signaling factors,
or molecules right over here.
These proteins, actually even
if they're on the surface
or even if they're within the cell,
we would call them receptors.
So that right over there,
that is a receptor.
And the molecules themselves,
these things that bind on to the receptor,
we call them the ligand.
In general, it's the
general term for something
that binds on to a receptor.
And so at that point where
you bind on to a receptor,
whether you're talking
about the paracrine process
or endocrine,
actually endo, I left a C out here,
endocrine signaling,
this process where it latches on,
we would call that a signal perception.
And then when this protein
somehow changes its shape,
or starts catalyzing a reaction,
or inhibiting a reaction,
we would call this the
signal transduction.
It's bringing the signal into the cell.
And then you have,
you have your actual cellular response.
So hopefully you appreciate that
as just a bit of an overview
of how cells can signal with each other.
And in future videos we'll go
into a little bit more detail.
Especially the endocrine system,
and our understanding of hormones.